the first signs of civil unrest since
the taliban returned to power in
afghanistan are emerging small
demonstrations have been reported in a
handful of cities witnesses say the
taliban shot dead three protesters who
were waving the national flag in
jalalabad meanwhile taliban fighters are
reported to have fired shots into the
air to disperse crowds trying to reach
kabul airport the islamist insurgents
have said repeatedly that they have
changed and want peace but many afghans
find that hard to believe
[Applause]
defiant scenes on the streets of
jalalabad
the taliban may say they have changed
[Music]
but their response to this show of
dissent tells a different story
dozens had gathered to lower the
militant group's banner and raise the
national flag when taliban fighters
opened fire
these distraught journalists say they
were beaten as they tried to cover the
protest
people with afghan flags and their hands
were chanting long live afghanistan and
saying the flag shouldn't be desecrated
we were taking pictures and videos as
they reached the roundabout
a taliban started hitting me with a gun
from behind as i was filming
shots also rang out today outside the
international airport in kabul
as the taliban sought to disperse crowds
attempting to flee
as foreign evacuation flights ramp up
there were unconfirmed reports of a
stampede at a gate at the airport
meanwhile the country's new rulers have
been meeting other political forces
taliban leader mullah abdul ghani barada
who arrived back from exile on tuesday
is expected to play a key role in
negotiations the taliban say they are
seeking to form an inclusive islamic
government
speaking from exile in the united arab
emirates ousted president ashraf ghani
back talks between the militant group
and top former government officials and
said he was in talks to return to
afghanistan
more now from journalists franz marty in
kabul franz what more can you tell us
about these anti-taliban protests
according to sources on the ground
protests were organized on social media
by civil society activists
who put out messages when to go on the
street and show support to the national
flag
i was told that uh beyond
supporting the national flag uh voicing
the national flag the protests didn't
had like a further agenda so they they
weren't like asking for a specific
political system or specific leaders um
then in jalalabad scenes turned ugly
with the taliban opening fire and also
like attacking journalists as was shown
in your report
in assad about and host all the cities
where similar protests were held there
have also been reports about gunfire but
their scenes have seemed to be less
dramatic however
figures close to the taliban
semi-official taliban
spokesperson had now announced that the
taliban are set to conduct a clearing
operation in hosts and have imposed the
indefinite curfew
which seems to be
a reaction to today's protests in host
which all shows that yeah the taliban
apparently don't like this and and are
not afraid to act decisively against it
we'll see what what developments occur
with that clearing operation taliban
co-founders you well know mullah
abdulgani bharata is one of a number of
group leaders who have returned from
exile tell us more about him and what
part he's likely to play
mullah baghdad
is of the old guard of the taliban he
was then
arrested spent years in a pakistani
prison
which apparently also impeded his health
he was then
released
in an effort to move forward
peace talks uh he was up on his release
appointed as the leader of the political
office
and presided over the negotiations that
led to the u.s taliban agreement signed
in february 2020 and subsequent
negotiations between the taliban and the
then afghan government
um his return
to uh afghanistan it is unclear what
exactly it means uh because there hasn't
been any official statement since he
returned however it might signal that
the taliban
decide of how and who to appoint at the
highest leadership the taliban have kind
of ousted the the former government from
afghanistan but so far they haven't
appointed um
their highest leader it is also
noteworthy that like uh main taliban
leader haibatullah and other deputies
their whereabouts are unknown and it is
unclear if and when they will surface
what's the latest from the airport franz
there are reports of the taliban
actually opening fire
the scenes at the airport are still
chaotic so the taliban have set up
checkpoints outside the airport inside
the airport parts of the airport are
secured by uh international forces and
uh then there have been hundreds and
thousands of people um
storming uh were like going to the
airport hoping to get out there have
been reports that taliban turned some
away beat some up
and uh given that there has been no
clear procedure
there have been huge crowd that
sometimes also caused stampedes
there have been reports about warning
shots uh that then might also have
injured people however with the
casualties it's very often hard to tell
whether this was due to the shooting or
just uh the crowd being out of control
and people being trampled
franz marty in kabul thank you so much
franz
for more we're joined by mark jacobson
he was an advisor to
former u.s secretary of defense ash
carter and also served as deputy nato
representative in afghanistan from 2009
to 2011.
the german government has admitted sir
operational errors in afghanistan
president biden continues to defend his
decision was the troop withdrawal a
mistake
well i've argued for months that the
troop withdrawal is a mistake the biden
administration set up a false choice
between
endless war and full withdrawal and
there were a lot of other choices so we
know that a small u.s uh and little
larger nato contingent a total of about
7 000 troops or so uh we now see what it
was holding together
we also know that one of the major
mistakes was
making very clear to the taliban and to
the afghan government that there would
be no more air support
and i'm not sure
any
uh well-trained military would be able
to operate
against its enemy without air support so
those were major mistakes there were
other things that could have been done a
longer-term training mission which is
not war
uh to help the afghan national security
forces fight
just briefly sir why do you think the
president did make that clear that there
would be no more air support was that to
joust the uh the the leadership in
afghanistan
uh it's an interesting thought but uh
you know what it really did was uh ended
up encouraging the taliban showing them
that there was a a true point beyond
which uh the afghan national security
forces would not not be able to
to fight um i think that the president
biden as the administration's been
saying is laser focused on withdrawal
and i do not think that they gave good
weight to the consequences in fact today
uh there have been reports that uh the
cia explained uh to the white house that
you would see this sort of collapse of
the afghan government i don't know the
timeline yet because i haven't read the
report but this is as we speak
in fact right now as we speak the
secretary of defense is briefing on this
uh very subject and what's going on in
afghanistan in his remarks on monday
biden said we gave them every chance to
determine their own future what we could
not provide them was the will to fight
for that future so essentially blaming
the country's leaders and security
forces for refusing to fight
do you agree with that assessment
absolutely not there are 60 000 afghan
national security forces who've been
killed fighting the taliban you still to
this day and i know there's not much
news coverage of it if any uh there are
still afghan units that are fighting the
taliban uh right now whether up in
tangier or in the south units that
refuse to surrender
you know if you think about the
situation the ansf were in and then
being told look we know the taliban are
in the middle of an offensive but we're
out of here and our air power's out of
here what choice did they really have
but to lay down their arms and maybe cut
a better deal
to try and get uh get their make sure
their families were safe i mean
the the withdrawal is what made the
collapse inevitable
what can international allies do or
maybe even have to do to stabilize the
situation in the country
well right now the most important thing
allies can do is get their foreign
nationals and the afghans who help
support the nato effort out
and i realize that the u.s really has to
bear the brunt of this effort uh given
the military heavy airlift capabilities
uh but we've seen you know it's it's
been really slow and problematic in
kabul and without getting into the
details there are some glimmers of hope
but if the plan is to get seven to nine
thousand uh just americans and afghans
uh and some other foreign nationals out
per day
um they're gonna have to do a lot better
um it's just been a couple of hundred uh
if that the last couple of days let's
hope today proves to be better but the
focus again has to be on getting people
out and then the international community
can work together to hold the taliban to
what i think are empty promises uh about
uh you know respect for human rights and
women's rights but if the taliban want
to go down that path and the
international community has to work
together to hold them to that promise
mark jacobson much appreciated sir
anytime thank you
a plane carrying evacuees from
afghanistan has arrived at frankfurt
airport the first of a number of special
lufthansa flights bringing german
citizens and afghans to germany military
planes took them from kabul to tashkent
in uzbekistan from there the lufthansa
flight brought them to frankfurt germany
has taken 500 people out of afghanistan
since the taliban took over here are
some of the first arrivals
it was really awful for my child it was
terrible for the three of us
people were shooting the soldiers were
shooting they wanted to prevent people
from storming the
is airport things were getting worse
every day
i didn't know how to help my family
everything is so bad
i could only save us
but i can't save the rest of my family
we pushed our way through
and then my little son fell down
and then an american showed kindness
and he realized we were at the end of
our tether he took our passports and
said i'm going to check if everything is
okay
i'm happy to be back and i thank the
german government for making it possible
for us to be here again